[Music]
well welcome it's been 3 years since I
seen you I feel like we had this amazing
conversation the last time that you did
this oh so long ago and I just remember
thinking we're gonna be best friends
we're gonna hang out all the time well
la is a big place and you live like in
the mountains yeah like a hidden oak
valley somewhere something like that
yeah yeah it was a barrier that was a
barrier like I have ideas from civility
live in Santa Monica and I'm like you
know can do bye have a great life right
well you're an Eastsider and you're the
first person that I've had over to the
downtown outpost of the podcast hey hey
hey breaking in this new space and it's
very exciting to be a demo area now I'm
proximate so perhaps we will part ways
laughter this and then and and rejoin
for social frivolity yeah well there's
so many restaurants and things down here
that I need a reason to try right well
I'll go with you there we go
when I go on your Instagram I'm like
he's always hanging out with super cool
people having a great time like I have
FOMO looking but there's a lot of
problems with social media but one of
the good things is that even though I
haven't seen you in three years like I
still feel very connected to you and
everything that you're doing so I'm just
delighted to have you here today I love
talking to you I mean we talked for
three hours last time and I felt like it
was 30 minutes
it's such a fun mind meld so I'm happy
to be back
well excited to get into it with you
today although I will admit at the
outset I'm feeling very naked right now
I'm like a control freak about this
whole thing and when I have a guest on I
do tons of research and quite often
somebody has a book coming out and I
make a point of reading that book so I
know what to talk to them about and we
had this conversation offline over the
last day
because your book is coming out I have
not had the opportunity to read it yet
and we wanted to go ahead with this
anyway so we're gonna talk about a book
that I have not read witch or bull which
i think is very appropriate because no
one listening to this has right either
so it's like them getting to ask me
questions of like why should I read this
right but the the ballast of like who's
in control of this podcast has shifted
now you you have to shoulder some
responsibility to make it go well but
also that kind of makes sense like I
need to convince you that it's worth
your time mmm you know and that's
hopefully what I do right well first of
all I'm super proud of you that you got
this done when we first spoke it was the
very beginning of this adventure you had
said about beginning to crack this book
open and very big took you three years
but you did it yeah it was about that's
it took me about two years to do it and
then you turn it in and then it's a year
until it comes out right more or less
right so there's a lot of refining and
and all these amazing details that
publishers are really good at which I am
NOT and then it exists which so fun like
it was it was so nascent and such like a
dream in my head and so scary in a
mountain that I could see from the
valley when we first spoke mm-hmm and
now it's a physical thing that I can
hold in my hands that now is given away
to strangers who it'll become their
experience now right I love it they hate
it it means nothing to them like I can't
control that anymore it's now out how do
you feel about that
I feel pretty Zen about it because I
live in LA surrounded by a bunch of
artists who make art they make TV shows
they make music and I've witnessed them
process this experience where they work
on an album for years and it boom it
comes out mm-hmm maybe there's some
chatter about it maybe not and then
they're like wow like what do I do it's
not like when you give birth to a child
and now you have to raise the child
forever
it's out and it's a thing and then
whether it catches the zeitgeist of
culture or not there's not a lot you can
do about it right I would say one one
distinction perhaps is that being a
writer and putting a book out in the
world there's a certain responsibility
that you have as as the author to help
people care about it if you're a
musician or if you're making a TV show
you've got a gigantic infrastructure
behind you to get people interested in
watching that television program it's a
little bit different when you when you
write a book yes you have the publisher
and that publishing house has a public
you know published you have a publicist
and all that kind of stuff but one thing
I've learned is you really have to carry
that mantle yourself and I know you're
doing that you're going on this like
you're gonna be gone I'm like a book
tour for a while
yeah it's I'm doing just a few book
events and then we'll see if other ones
manifest because I really enjoy talking
to people in live it's really fun but I
don't I mean yes I do carry that medal
because I believe my intention with
writing the book was write the book I
wish I could have read when I was 23 and
my identity was totally in flux mm-hmm
and I was evangelical Christian and gay
and didn't know how to reconcile those
things and was doing my best and I
wished I had somebody a little further
along that that I could find that would
speak my language because a lot of times
the sexuality faith thing is such a
precipice that when people when people
really reconcile it their faith and
they're all they're they're so wounded
by the tradition in which they were
raised that they reject it completely
and so when I was still in it I was
trained to fear people who rejected the
faith as deceived and wrong and so I
feared them so I couldn't find someone
who was still speaking my language who
could like Usher me into a new way of
thinking and so I feel the burden of
like doing my best and make sure young
me whatever that looks like right gets
gets the chance to read this book it's
interesting you rejected the notion of
being the rejecter yeah and it's like
this journey to finding this middle
place of comfort with faith and your
sexuality yeah on the face like we
chatted a little bit about this an email
like on the face of the book it sort of
seems like this is going to be a book
about like finding your passion and like
lighting out on the territory and like
yeah you know exploring your you know
finding you know finding your dream by
like rejecting corporate America and
perhaps that's you know the the hook on
the lure that might bring in that young
reader but then you kind of hoodwink
them and take them on this on this
journey that has a lot more depth and
nuance to it yeah which i think is a big
part of being human where you especially
when you're young have lofty goals big
ideas for your future and and you go
forth and reach for them and then you
might realize that they're counterfeit
and they're not what you thought and you
reject them and you try something else
and really all of that pendulum swing
see-sawing of life and seasons of life
is a search for self acceptance identity
completion wholeness and walking in that
and and so what I thought was I want my
dream career and I want to be a writer
and I want to be known as a adventurous
guy who does risky things was was really
kind of the smoke from a deeper fire of
I want to be ok with me mm-hmm
and my bike trip really started peeling
those layers back like once it got real
hard once it got no longer cool and fine
and it just became laborious and I
really wanted to quit and all these
things it started to it started to teach
me lessons that I didn't even anticipate
right like am i doing this because this
is what I really want to do or am I
doing this because I want to know be
known as somebody who would
you this exactly which is I think a lot
of people never differentiate those two
things and they don't realize that
they're actually performing in such a
way to be known as right Blanc but it
was in the doing that you had the the
doing was the vehicle for answering that
question for yourself right there's a
lot of talk in the Christian world and
maybe outside of it as well about what
legacy will you leave like what's your
legacy what's your legacy which is a
beautiful idea but also is the same
thing as how do I want people to talk
about me like what will my reputation be
and I don't know I think if you're
worried about your reputation rather
than worried about who you are first and
let that let your reputation radiate out
and don't worry about how you're coming
across worry about who you are and then
how you come across will be great
I just people I think people get the
dominoes out of order yeah well it's
difficult is really difficult because
that requires the heart the hard work
the heavy lifting of looking inward you
know and I think I think most people are
either afraid of that or we're just
socially conditioned to not do that and
to get our validation externally I I
listened to the other day - you're
you've all her re-interview which was
fantastic is the best one I've heard of
him yet and it's not often that you
listen to a podcast and change your
behavior the next day but I've never
meditated in my life except like once
when my friend gave me a group
meditation for my birthday and the way
you guys spoke about his meditation
practice and really specifically what
when he said eighteen years ago he did
visit of a plasma and his teacher told
him to just think about his breathing
for 10 minutes and he couldn't do it for
10 seconds and and just being centered
and starting your day of that like that
I woke up today and sat in my bed
and found like a YouTube guided haha and
and just grounded myself in my body and
really listened to my breathing for ten
minutes and then if a thought came in I
observed it outside of that thought and
let it float away like a balloon and and
it was this amazing moment where I
started my day realizing that I exist
that I am here that that is amazing and
that I am worthy I don't know it was
this just one ten minute meditation and
one in this tiny little moment of your
day just starting your day like that and
it was I don't know it was really
impactful and and simple and felt like a
little blessing on the day and I think
it's gonna be a new practice I mean it
you've all it does 30 45 60 day silent
retreats and meditates 2 hours a day you
know we'll see if I get there well it's
super intimidating when you hear that
right but when you hear him say yeah he
couldn't go 10 seconds without you know
his mind attacking him and then in the
wake of these three gigantic books that
have quite literally reshaped culture
and how we talk about so many issues for
him to credit those books the ideas that
he that he formulated in order to write
those books so almost solely to his
meditation practice is one of the most
profound yeah through lines that yeah
the through line that really hit me and
was the impetus of the challenge that
changed my behavior was he said it
teaches you how to focus or the way he
says it focus or at London's accent and
I realize very hard for me to focus on
anything for more than 10 seconds I mean
we have our obviously our phones you
have someone coming in the room there's
a leaf blower outside your brain is
leaping constantly maybe now more than
it's ever been and the ability in
writing this book taught me that I
really struggle with focus I could write
I had to do 20 minute spurts and then
give myself 10 minutes allowed to look
at my phone and 20 minutes again
minutes twenty minutes it was like oh
that's I wrote the I think you've all
wrote sapiens like a year after we did
our first podcast oh that he's honest he
just misses his ability to focus is
extraordinary because he exercises that
muscle through meditation and I was like
wow if I could focus imagine the clarity
of thought and I was thinking as I was
going to bed last night which is why I
took a note of it reflecting on that
podcast there are like three types of
thinking in the world there's like the
particulate thinker the categorical
thinker and then the systems thinker and
the particulate thinker only responds to
like thing right in front of their face
which is I think most people they don't
analyze their life they're not thinking
about an issue their thing we're
reacting read they're reacting every
moment the categorical thinker maybe is
somebody who like writes for The
Washington Post about politics they know
a lot about a category and they think
about it in a little bigger picture but
if I asked them about psychology or
invite the environment they would be
like I don't know anything about that
you've all is a true systems thinker he
flies above the earth and looks at the
ecosystem of all things and somehow can
synthesize it and pull the relevant
patterns out and just speak it so
crisply and clearly where it makes the
world make a little more sense and I
know I'm a systems thinker I'm nowhere
near him but that's like I always am
like feeling and absorbing the patterns
that transpose over everything like the
unity of truth through nature human
behavior I just see it like a unity in
the way things are and I want to
exercise that muscle I think it would be
a gift to humanity if you did that I
mean I think I agree with you I think
what's unique about you and perhaps what
distinguishes you from you vols approach
is that your gift is in yes you're a
systems thinker and you can find this
unity but it's all through the prism of
your own personal
experience and you convey it with a
personal truth that also strikes a court
of universal truth and I think that's
why everyone connects to your writing so
deeply because you may be talking about
something that happened to you or
something that happened to you you know
with respect to or relationship that you
have but we can all find some
commonality in that experience like
that's that's where I feel your power
and your strength is and what you write
Wow thank you well I Eve all's not he
doesn't talk about like he's not
filtering it through his own personal
variants it's very it's it's sort of
antiseptic yeah it's yeah and I mean
that's the kind of beauty of if you look
at the world like an orchestra everyone
has their instrument and their note to
play and it each one brings its own
important moment to the symphony mm-hmm
and maybe the way I communicate what
I've learned or a truth or a feeling
well the way that I communicate will
impact someone more than the antiseptic
just history synthesised uh-huh by a
different type of book and that's why I
like encourage people when they're like
I don't even know I don't have anything
original to say you know I don't know if
I should write I don't and I'm like no
one has lived your life in that exact
way if you can just write truthfully
about your experience that will have
value because you exist and you have
value period but it requires you to
connect deeply with your interior life
yeah and you have that you have you know
meditation aside whether you've never
met date again you're very in touch with
your emotional landscape and you have an
ability to bring voice to that I think
I've thought a lot about that because I
don't know why I am that way but I think
it has to do with when I was a kid and
realizing I was gay and realizing the
world was not made for me I didn't feel
safe
I didn't think oh I'm not safe
I didn't feel like I was fitting in and
in that moment my brain got real curious
about how everything works I needed to
understand the lay of the land so that I
could find ways to fit in and not as a
circuit loss mechanism and so very early
on I learned to like jump up above the
city and look where the roads go so I
don't get lost where a lot of people if
if it were if you're just like handsome
or pretty in eighth grade and
everything's working great for you and
you had no awkward moment you just float
right on through and you never even
think how how is this happening you're
just reacting and it's working out for
you
right so let's go back there you grow up
gay in an evangelical Christian
environment and from what I understand
you you felt compelled to kind of hide
from that I suppose maybe you have a
different word for other than that and
to kind of exert some semblance of
masculinity to prove to the world that
you were other than perhaps who you were
or are and that became expressed in
being this adventurer and and trying to
show the world this masculine you know
version of yourself
or your idea of what like a man a young
man is supposed to be yeah I think
there's a lot of gay men who in those
early years are they become either
performative ly masculine or their
natural disposition and they're like
feminine expression causes them so much
hurt that they retreat and then I mean
they're really wounded by their
environment and they run away to West
Hollywood and finally are free you know
and they're at the club and they're like
fu mom and dad I'm free you know I like
compensating in the other extreme
exactly
I I was in middle school I had a really
high voice and it must have been really
feminine I mean I had uh middle
schoolers say ask me if I was a girl and
I'm like I don't think I am I think I'm
a boy but I think in it's not like I sat
down and made decisions I was just
reacting to the world trying to survive
and I tried to control the way I spoke
so as not to get asked that again I
tried to control the way I moved my
hands so as not to be noticed
I learned to be funny and silly and
wacky and that was a thing where I
thought well if I make fun of myself
I'll beat them to it and take the wind
out of their sails so if I'm the funny
guy I can insulate myself from mockery
and there's I mean all of these horrible
and it worked it worked really well to
the point that by sophomore year of high
school I was pretty popular
I was really well-liked I by junior year
like all my best friends were like the
football and baseball players straight
guys and and I don't know like I I was
able to I don't want to say hide because
I didn't feel like I was hiding I just
felt like I was me but I was playing the
game that everyone plays to fit into the
world the bread man but you knew you
knew you were gay I knew I was gay
I knew something was quote-unquote wrong
with me in third grade because the kids
were talking about boners and they asked
me how what gives me boners and I said
bodybuilders on ESPN and they laughed
and so I was like oh I can't talk about
this and then in seventh grade I learned
what the word was for when you like that
stuff when you own when you are a boy
and you like boys but I didn't know that
it wouldn't go away I thought maybe like
many people do it was a phase mmm
and as senior year approached I realized
this probably isn't gonna change like
this is Who I am
right and at the same time I was willing
I was willing to believe that God could
bring a woman into my life that would
inflame my passions and you know maybe
I'm not attracted to all women maybe I'm
only attracted to my future wife and
when God brings her into my life it'll
be hot and heavy and I'll be I'll make
all the church happy and it'll be great
yeah well that has to be coming directly
from the doctrine that was getting
hammered into you every Sunday oh well
yeah and it's it's not always hammered
it is like death from a thousand cuts of
just talking about one Sunday they'll
talk about how people who interpret the
Bible to get what they want are actually
deceived you know it's they're they're
taking the Bible as a buffet and they
pick and choose what they want just to
serve their own self and so your truck
you're taught that's the worst way to
think and you're in your talk you know
adverse in Jeremiah the heart is
deceitful above all things so I'm
thinking okay so if I want something and
it's not approved in the Bible then
that's me rejecting God's Word and
that's me being selfish and seeking
that's me just being self seeking and
therefore I need to repent of that and
I'm just a selfish
and that's a that's a super highway to a
shame spiral total shame and total shame
spiral because the real kicker is sexual
identity is also tied into behavior and
so it took a while for the church to get
this language down but they were like
it's not a sin to be gay it is it it is
a sin to act on it mm-hmm and then
they'll say things like God gave you
this challenge he doesn't give you any
thing that he doesn't know that you can
accomplish he won't give you anything
you can't handle so he gave you this
calling to celibacy as an invitation to
true godly wisdom and that's a real
burden but yours but your love much for
that well and I believed that I was like
wow I must be so strong that God trusted
me with this burden and did you have
anyone that you could talk to honestly
no I had friends who I knew didn't
weren't super Christian it didn't take
it that seriously uh-huh
but but because I was so deep in the
faith and like wanted to prove how good
of a Christian I was I couldn't find
someone who was higher up on the piety
scale who was okay with gay marriage or
being gay so I couldn't find someone in
authority to look to I could find people
quote-unquote below me on the piety
scale who would just like would drink
and smoke and and they were just like
he'd hedonistic and so I'm like well
thank you for accepting me but you also
accept a lot of other things I don't
believe in so that's not really helping
right and your parents did they have any
awareness of what was going on with you
they did my dad apparently when I was
two years old asked my mom do you think
Jed is gay I don't know what I was doing
but I and my mom was really hurt by that
because she is a deep Bible believing
Christian woman you know and and was
like why would you speak that over our
son and I then just like my dad's I mean
then they got a divorce and my dad was
cheated and went to be with my stepmom
and bla bla so it was a whole hectic
chaotic world my older sister was really
damaged by the divorce my younger
brother had like physical disabilities
that they were really a it was chaos
my mother mm-hmm and so she couldn't
really worry about that not to mention
in this time in the 80s all of a sudden
she sees on the news that gay people are
dying by the tens of thousands by a
mystery gay cancer right and at the
church they're saying see the rewards
for sin is death and so well a plus B
equals C that's easy let me make sure
that let me pray that this does this
curse doesn't fall on Jed which I
totally understand her mindset there and
and I learned to not rock the boat as I
got older my sister is dating drug
dealers my little brother is has you
know his medical issues and so I'm like
okay I got to get straight A's I got to
be the best kid I can't rock the boat
and that continued that's a heavy burden
to carry as a young kid to on top of all
the rest of it and I just learned to do
my own thing and do well I mean I was
student body president in my high school
and my mom didn't know yeah really yeah
until some graduation and I was like I
have to get there early and she was like
why and I'm like well I have to give a
speech which is like why and I'm like
I'm student body president she was so
mad at me that I didn't tell her but I
had like built up this thing of like I'm
independent I do my own thing I'm not in
your hair right and on some level as
somebody who's who's carrying a certain
level of shame whether consciously or
unconsciously to compensate by being
this achiever right and that's actually
big in the gay community
they like the internalized shame creates
like superhumans because they're so
intent on proving that they are worthy
that they make a lot of money they get
good jobs they get a nice car I mean
that's like a big thing and so was there
a moment where you had a reckoning with
this and and became okay with with being
outwardly you know comfortable with it
or was it a slow progression of
acclimate it was a slow progression and
in my and then there was a moment of
reckoning for me it was
my mid-twenties began my deconstruction
of my faith in the sense where the the
infrastructure of my life which my
mother had blessed me with to keep me
safe and make the world make sense it's
like actually scientifically proven that
when you raise a kid in a structured
environment like in a faith community
they like are better prepared for the
world than if it's chaos and so I'm so
grateful for that but then as I'm
finding it for myself in my twenties
becoming more and more adult and diving
deeper and deeper into okay if I'm gay
and Christian well I'm tired of this I
need to figure it out and so I went all
the way at like 25 I went to a gay
conversion therapy meetings did oh my
god
tell me more about that yeah well it
started with a elder in my church really
confronted me and said you need to
figure this out and I was like okay and
she said I know a couple men who had
this struggle and God healed them of it
and now they're married with families
mm-hm and you should meet with them so I
met with a couple of these men and one
of them was inspiring he was fun
he was chatty he had a beautiful wife
and a daughter and he he was just like I
couldn't I lived the wild gay life in my
20s and I I couldn't shake the shame and
you know I went to these meetings and
God healed me and brought my wife into
my life and now I'm happy and he's like
it's not that I don't feel those
feelings anymore it's like I'm still
attracted to men but I choose my wife
Wow yeah and I was like and you're like
but dude you're gay Oh hundred percent
I'm like bro you're gay but but I also
don't I believe he does love his wife
and I believe they may have a great
marriage I'm
it seemed like they did maybe they were
putting it on their best performance but
I was like this is this is a real way of
being and what's interesting is in that
season of life also I would I had began
working off and on in Uganda for the
charity Invisible Children which we
talked about last time and they're in
tight like especially in the traditional
north you don't marry the person you
love so much as you you marry family set
it up it's a good deal she's fertile
she's not barren she'll give you ten
kids your kids can work the land your
family will grow marriage is a business
arrangement not an expression of
ultimate self-actualization with another
person and that's a very individualized
American Western idea and so I had seen
like Oh marriage especially in the Bible
is not just find your true love and live
happily ever after it's a it really like
God maybe intended marriage to be this
strategic partnership where you choose
the person daily even if it's hard and
so I was like maybe that's what I meant
to do maybe maybe it is what I said
before about the heart is deceitful like
maybe I'm being selfish wanting love and
so you go to gay conversion therapy yeah
which was this big meeting I went to one
of the I went to this other guy's house
and he was less he was less believable
in the sense that he seemed unhappy he
seemed unhappy to take me to this which
was interesting mmm because in my mind
he was living my dream which was he had
been healed of this thing that caused
conflict in my life conflict in my
family conflict in my community the fear
of loss of my entire Christian community
and he had been rescued from it by God
and was living with a wife and kids
and he was willing to take me to this
meeting and yet the feeling I got from
him was that there was an invisible gun
to his head
making him take
I feel so bad for that guy and I and and
he's budging Lee bringing you knowing
that he's you to this this burden that
he's carrying so I went to this meeting
and it was this man's bald man on stage
and and they're singing worship songs
and then he's talking about you know you
need to let go of it
whoever molested you whoever hurt you
whoever if your mother who over mothered
you your dad who abandoned you whoever
because that's the only reason that
right there has to be a cause scream out
and forgive them forgive them right now
and so I'm saying they're like no one
did like nobody did anything to me
I loved my childhood every minute of it
mmm what do I scream and everyone's
yelling and it it's just this weird
cacophony of noise and and then they're
there some testimonies get up and I'm
looking around the room and there's a
verse in the Bible that I'm gonna
paraphrase what Jesus says but it's like
I've come to give you life and life
abundant and you will no false teachers
by the fruit they bear if they bear good
fruit it is of the Lord if they bear bad
fruit it is not and so I was looking at
this and I'm like this is not good fruit
these people are so burdened by shame
and they are not alive they are not
radiant the people on stage who are
supposed to be beacons of Hope are like
cold dark zombies the people in the
audience or zombies the guy who brought
me is a zombie I'm like I don't think
this is life and life abundant right
it's it's life and resignation and my
brain started like but a little going
through like all these like factors of
okay well if you're raised with false
shame let me just like imagine what if
God is actually cool with me being gay
and yet all of society tells you it's
shameful you're raised in that shame and
you misappropriate the feeling or you
miss apply the feeling of shame as God's
judgment but
actually your community's judgment then
maybe we've got this all wrong
and so I right at that moment started to
break break break break break it down
how old were you I was like 26 I mean
that's a pretty good self-awareness I
mean well that's what I'm in middle
school I had to be like figure out what
am i what is the world I had to or else
I would be swallowed up mm-hmm
and the real kicker is around that time
maybe a year later I made a new really
close friend who was a couple years
younger than me and he didn't know I was
gay most of my friends did but I don't
always super signal that I'm gay
especially the people who were a little
oblivious and so he didn't know and we
spent all of our time together and this
was still I was in the headspace of
figuring it out I hadn't like realized I
was it was okay to be gay I was like
processing this and we were at this
point I think I was 26 or 27
I'd never kissed anybody I'd never held
hands with anybody it was like buried
buried buried and we would he would
sleep over all the time we spent 24
hours a day together he's just my best
friend straight as an arrow and in his
sleep he was a sleep cuddler he was like
a deep deep deep sleeper and he would
just throw his leg over me because he'd
like roll around we'd be sleeping on the
floor we'd been wherever and I would be
awakened with this jolt of like sexual
desire that I had never felt in my life
and I wasn't really aware because I had
sectioned off that side of my brain that
I was in love with him I had like
written a narrative that he's my best
friend we do everything together my soul
mate but I in love with attracted to
were things I had moved into a basement
that I wasn't allowed to look at access
or think about so I was interesting I
was compartmentalized self-aware
I was really self-aware in certain ways
and willfully ignorant others and he
would do this sleep cuddling all the
time and one night he was like laying
like laying on top of me basically in
his underwear and in this like rage of
desire I put my hand in his underwear
uh-huh and he woke up and it this is my
best friend who doesn't know I'm gay and
I'm touching him in his sleep basically
molesting him and he woke up and that
was the to this day darkest moment of
shame I have ever experienced it was a
feeling of out-of-body shame where I was
looking at myself and I didn't recognize
myself I was like oh my gosh and I will
never forget he said he sat up it was in
the dark and he just goes he said we
have to talk about this I'm an adult I'm
not six years old meaning like implying
like I'm molesting a child or something
and when I tell you that that landed on
me like the hardest I mean that's
definitely the hardest thing I've ever
heard and we processed it over months
and we're still best friends and he's
the most amazing give me the most grace
and the most forgiveness but that was
the true moment where I was like if I
don't tackle this head-on and I don't
open all the doors in the basement this
is why Catholic priests do this right
this is why when when you think you've
got something under control especially
sexuality you don't yeah the the
unhealthy expression of repressed
sexuality and emotion and it will
express itself you think it won't it
will that's a hundred percent of the
time and so that's amazing that you were
able to navigate that with your friend
though and maintain well that's a
testament to his wisdom kindness I mean
he's one of those amazing people in my
life and always will be
and he is a similar person in me where
he seeks first understanding he is a
very confident safe person and so as we
then processed me and he learned about
my journey with sexuality and their
oppression and all these things he
reached a place where he was like bro I
get it like he's like I'm straight I've
been kissing girls since I was 15 I
can't imagine being 26 and completely
removing sexuality out of my house had
like no sexual experiences none and I
was 26 imagine doing that I'm not
condoning or excusing anything any
priest has done but just imagine
suppressing that for 45 years you know
you can compartmentalize your life and
then you're in a position of power this
is why I like the cell it's the celibacy
requirement and Catholicism is a problem
yeah it doesn't work
it clearly knees are not wired to
function no way and no and it does
certainly what am I having that the
prohibition on on marriage just attracts
that type of person to a priesthood and
I'll tell you when I was deeply in love
with God wanting to serve Jesus and
people told me that I couldn't get
married and I wanted to be a good boy
and I wanted to excel I was really
attracted to that I was like well then
maybe I can marry God and then be in a
position of like respect and finally
like I can turn in this thing this ball
and chain in my life for a crown on my
head like what a great exchange but the
trick is you never get rid of that bond
chain because it's woven into your DNA
right the idea is that if you then do
that it will go away it will vanish it
will dissipate that has to be similar to
what goes on in the minds of so many of
these guys
oh I it must be I mean we it's so funny
when you like listen to you've all her
are you listen to these like people
who've studied the evolution of man and
evolution of life and you realize that
pretty much everything we do is so we
can end up having sex right like why do
you brush your teeth so your teeth are
white so they're not falling out of your
mouth so that someone doesn't think
you're gross so that you can kiss them
so that it's like why do you want a good
job why do you it's like so that you can
procreate have a family I mean that's
like so deep in our wiring and then
obviously there's like complex
scientific theories of like why
homosexuality is 3 to 10% of the
population but it's got to be in there
somewhere like our sexuality is wired
into us well it's interesting to me that
this was going on right around the time
you were 27 which memory serves me is
kind of around the same time that you
had this idea to do this bike ride right
you now stood three years before you
actually did it
and you did it at 30 right so what is
the relationship between that desire to
embark on that adventure and this kind
of internal struggle that you were
having coming to terms with your
sexuality and who this person Jed is
well I it's a perfect example of me look
me still operating in a
compartmentalized fashion I was dealing
with my sexuality deconstruction faith
thing over here and that was giving me
deep anxiety in my core and yet I was in
my job and I saw a 30 coming and I was
like whoa when you're 30 you aren't a
kid anymore you're not allowed to just
like not know what's going on that was
like when you're in your 20s whoa 30 and
and I was in a job I loved loved but it
wasn't a job I really chose for myself
it was a job I was working with friends
I was doing important work but I was
like if I don't if I can choose my own
career now's when I should do it and
what do I want that to be and so I
thought well I need to pursue my dream
career of being a writer
I'm too
it's like embarrassing to write a memoir
in my 20s because like I just got to
earth like what am i doing so give me a
let me go on a wild trip and then at
least if I write about that it'll be
objectively interesting so the idea of
writing about it was integral change
idea itself yes and there was this idea
on some level you were harboring this
dream of being a writer totally it's
hard to imagine you doing anything
differently and I have a very hard time
picturing you in law school well I love
law school because it is a lot of
reading and writing as you know but I I
liked learning how civilization works
like property law and tort law like
these things all these words I had heard
in the news all of a sudden the like
specific ways in which if you have the
intent to even touch someone that can be
a battery even if it's nothing you know
it's like all these like little detail I
found that is endlessly fascinating and
realizing that law is actually the
imagined infrastructure of civilization
itself
it is it is and and I just had never
really put that together so law school
was this like endless discovery of the
way the world works which I fancy myself
a systems thinker so seeing that it's a
what you you're the greatest gift of law
school is it trains you to think in a
very specific way yeah and I kind of
didn't ever think I would be some fancy
John Grisham trial attorney or I didn't
know I didn't know I just thought maybe
if I get this tool and my tool belt
it'll influence the direction of my life
but how much of it was driven by that
that child inside of you who's trying to
be the good boy a 100% of you I was like
I need to be impressive because the core
of a big piece of my core being is a
blemish mm-hmm fast forward to you
sitting in a office working for a cruise
line right like in House Counsel
was and and that was the perfect example
that was during law school and it was a
perfect sample of I've made more money
that summer than I'd ever made in my
life and it was lifeless I I mean I made
some really good friends that summer as
like human beings are always interesting
and fun but just the work itself that
I'm so glad I did that because that
really woke me up quickly - oh you are
not the type of person that can survive
this like you will die in a cage and and
so that's why I was like okay well like
I'm just gonna go work for this charity
and make no money and be their lawyer
because I got to do something right and
these were these were guys that you met
at USC film school right mm-hmm
and for for people that didn't listen to
our first conversation Invisible
Children this is this incredible
nonprofit organization most famously
known for the Kony 2012 video that like
exploded the internet listen to our
first conversation we go really into it
yeah yeah yeah which is the only time
I've ever done that on a podcast really
talked about that yet doctor in that way
mm-hmm it's a it was a complicated thing
what happened with that it's very hard
to unpack it yeah
and that's a cool gig right if you're
gonna be working with your friends
you're traveling back and forth to
maganda and DC and meeting with samantha
power and the Obama administration and
getting laws passed I mean that was
really cool yeah and you're like five
seconds out of Law School
yeah and yet I was really aware that it
wasn't something I had chosen I had come
alongside my friends to help them do a
thing which was I did for five years and
was really life-changing no doubt but I
did feel like I felt I don't know what
it is to use Christian language I felt a
calling on my life that I had something
I was supposed to do mm-hmm it's
interesting that you had that awareness
because juxtaposing that against this
drive to be Percy
in a certain way as this you know good
person doing important things most
people would have relented to you know
the gestalt of the responsible you know
path of security and you know the high
paying lawyer job and and and stayed
with that for perhaps decades only to
act on that impulse you know when it
might be too late well and I don't want
to give myself to credit because I
didn't have college debt I was I had a
lot of financial aid at USC and then my
parents paid for law school because I'm
a privileged kid from Nashville and so I
entered the world able to just like
survive on $400 rent and bean and cheese
burritos ready to roll you know I'm
saying and that is a very that is a
serious but which most people I know now
I'm 35 are still paying huge college
debt yeah and and what most people do
and what I did was in addition to that
debt I I was able to tolerate a semi
intolerable professional existence by
compensating by buying a bunch of
right now you're you're so miserable and
annoying a car I can't afford yeah you
know it's always like a little bit
outside of your grasp and that that's
the death knell because that's what gets
you hooked and that's what leads to that
idea like oh I can't ever leave this
because my life is now big and I have to
maintain this right
oh yeah the accumulating of things that
were - they were band-aids for your
frustration because what else you gonna
do otherwise you just you'd go to sleep
when you go back to the job again well
and that was the real circumstantial
privilege of immediately beginning my
professional life working at Invisible
Children I was surrounded by people
making pennies who were there for the
passion of ending a war in Central East
Africa and interns volunteering their
time so it was very uncool if I pulled
up in a BMW uh-huh
that's like not the culture right the
culture was to sleep on the floor to
stay up all night to call your senator
to call your Congressman to go to Uganda
it was like
deeply woven in and and my Christian
upbringing it's like sacrifice service
all they say it really scratched a lot
of itches and I loved it mm-hmm so much
well I think it speaks to you know the
the the next move that you make and this
decision to embark on this this ride
from Oregon to Patagonia speaks to this
theme that that that you kind of address
in the very first pages of the book
which is this tension between these
mixed messages that that were given when
we're kind of coming of age which is on
the one hand you know seek the seek the
you know the career that's gonna be that
put you on an upwardly mobile trajectory
and then out of the other side of the
mouth of that same person is you know
think different or you know leave your
passion and those but up against each
other and it becomes very difficult to
reconcile what fits your own personal
blueprint yeah I mean that's the thing
is is the the circumstances of your
youth often deeply influenced I mean
always influenced that chain of events
in your 20s if you were raised where
your parents were in crushing credit
card debt and life was falling apart you
you think I'm not gonna be like them I'm
gonna be financially responsible I'm
gonna do the opposite if you're I have
friends who were raised in fabulous
wealth in Texas and they went on to be
barefoot serving the homeless I ain't
gonna be like that and they're gonna
drive a beat-up Camry to show that they
don't want daddy's money and so there's
like a lot of identity like pendulum
fluctuation there but I totally
understand that it's society's duty to
actually give you a certain flow chart
of how to make it in this world because
is really hard to do it to figure it out
on your own so I don't fault society for
like telling us here's how you do it but
I also would hope that society would say
there are a million ways to do this
don't get sucked into the like to the
allure of thinking you have to do it
this way and if you don't you're gonna
fail mm-hm and I really think with the
gig economy and them and what's
happening with now now that Millennials
are in in their 30s and late 20s they're
they're discovering really that they
that old pathway is not functioning the
way it used to and that's why I mean
there's I don't know the stats but huge
numbers of people my age and younger
don't work in offices don't have
traditional Jo anybody that has a normal
job I I swear to you I have to think
about it yeah like I live in LA and to
like go on a hike on a Tuesday at 11
a.m. is the North's normal thing in the
world it's so true and it's I don't know
and that's like I mean I think you know
la I remember when I have a vivid memory
of when I first moved to LA and I was a
lawyer in San Francisco and I moved here
for a law firm job and this is pre gig
economy but there's something very
unique and strange about Los Angeles
because you could go into a Starbucks at
2:00 in the afternoon and it would be
packed with people and you're like did
any these people work like they all look
like they took a shower this morning
but like how does that even make sense I
remember I just blew my mom this city is
madder than any other yeah but it
expanded my horizons of what was
possible I mean prior to moving here I I
never it never would have occurred to me
that you could find gainful employment
pursuing something that you cared about
in a way that that defied our
traditional notions of what that social
contract looks like yes because of the
entertainment industry somebody who like
who's very talented at carving faces out
of styrofoam can actually have a career
you know I exactly when you're like yeah
but that's what you're saying speak so
clearly to the importance of
modeling or representation of different
ways of being I mean in terms of
representation in arts where you have
people of color you have people with
different abilities and and talents
coming up in storytelling I know that
when I was a kid watching Will & Grace
changed my life
because I saw I thought being gay was
flamboyant and a pride parade and then I
saw will who was a lawyer in New York
and I was like oh you can just be you
don't have to be in a thong yeah you can
just hang out and be normal
yeah we have this idea that that every
young gay male is the kid who sang down
the right way which is straight if he is
like fantastic but that wasn't me and so
I didn't see though I thought oh okay
all this all these things that the
Christians are saying are true you
either become hyper sexual and hate God
and you're in a parade this is like I
don't want to assume that that's true
I'm just saying that's what I perceived
and I was like well where are the like
happy married gay couples who like are
clothed and have jobs like where are
they and that was what really powerful
with Will and Grace and then seeing
that's what I love about all the
different people you have on your
podcast they show you like all the
different careers and adventures they've
been on and expertise is you see model
you see model different ways of making
it in this world and making contributing
something important and that's really
encouraging to me about Gen Z or
whatever it is and Millennials figuring
out what they're doing I think there's
going to be a lot of surprising
contributions because of a certain level
of just modeled access to I think that's
right of being I think that's right I
mean I think you know me you see it I
mean you see it manifest already you
know people who are driven not by
salaries and 401ks and benefits but by
impact like how is how is taking this
job going to move the needle in terms of
making the world a better place like
that's certainly nothing that occurred
to me when I was looking for my first
job or
second job or my third job but that is
very much the mindset of young people
now and amidst all the craziness and the
chaos and the lack of civility and
everything that's going on right now
that gives me tremendous hope and
optimism for the future me too
and I and I wonder I mean you have kids
this exact age of just I'm so curious
about what the brand af-- ocation of
identity is gonna do to young people
where you're like worried about your
brand in eighth grade like oh I need to
wear this shirt I need to post this
photo how many how many likes is it
gonna get that's such a tired
conversation everyone that's a parent is
like freaking out but it's I'm I'm
curious I don't have skin in the game
I'm just like way out yeah like are they
going to become are they gonna get
burned on not getting a job because
someone went deep in their Instagram
have found and found something or are
people gonna become more open to just
the fact that people grow and change and
I think we're gonna have to be yeah your
dominance documented and I think this
idea of generations is being accelerated
you know it's no longer boomers Gen Xers
yeah Gen Y it's like now to every every
three years is a new generation you know
my older boys are 22 and 23 they're that
pendulum has swung towards analog like
they're really I mean that's interesting
yeah they have Instagram accounts maybe
once a month they post they're not on
Facebook they're not on Twitter they're
not they're not interested yeah you know
which is cool maybe that's a reaction to
you know how my wife and I are living or
just what they're seeing amongst their
peers but that was very interesting to
see both of them make that choice and
now I have younger daughters who are
very different from that they're a
totally different generation even though
they're only separated by a short number
of years I I don't know how to delineate
Christian influence from millennial
influence of my own life but I know
making an impact was a really big deal
to me always
and I don't I don't know if it's like
because you're a brand ambassador for
Jesus you need to be on your best
behavior and you need to be an excellent
brand ambassador
that's like wired into me in college in
high school and that's still a huge part
of me now with my writing
I just my only dream is that some people
who feel trapped in their identity feel
trapped in their tradition feel and
don't see a way out read this book and
it just shot it just models the
sometimes difficult sometimes tender
exiting out of that entrapment yeah and
and I and I what's fun about the time we
live in is normally when you're a writer
you write a book and maybe you get some
letters in the mail from people who were
impacted by your words
maybe someone writes a nice review I
write online mostly and I see people
being impacted by my via the immediacy
of it is astonishing and it feels
incredible the very first sentence of
the book is if discontent is your
disease travel as medicine which is such
a awesome how long did it take
you to come over that I mean the
pressure you know the first sentence of
things it's like it's so important like
I just I was like I read that and I was
like it's so great not my God thank you
how many versions of this sentence dude
that's what that's what I knew I wanted
to say in the first sentence and then I
would I'd wrote I'm sure I wrote it a
different way and would come back two
weeks later and look at it and be like
mmm close but not there and then I don't
know I mean I didn't I don't I don't
think my words are that precious like I
don't labor over them if it makes sense
it can stay if it's too cliche or too
cheesy it's gotta go uh-huh
and I I just believe that you know the
book is called to shake the sleeping
self and there's like parts of you that
need to be removed
from their comfort zone to even wake up
and you can't do it yourself you have to
remove yourself from the routine from
the thing you know and travel is a
perfect way to do that right so the
architecture of the book is you're gonna
ride your bike from Oregon to Patagonia
we're gonna go along for this ride with
you and you are going to shake the
sleeping self you are gonna have this
reckoning with who you are and as we
kind of talked about at the outset going
into it
the reader is perhaps lured into this
notion that this is going to be yeah
it's gonna be a journey of
self-discovery but but it's going to be
so much more than that it's going to be
a reckoning of sexuality and faith in
your place in the world and and all of
these themes that you then explore when
you embarked on this when you when you
began this when you either when you
decided to do this this bike journey or
you began the journey what level of
awareness did you have that this was
going to be your opportunity to really
work this out for yourself and how much
of it was all I'm gonna do this crazy
adventure so everyone you know thinks of
me as this you know masculine
adventurous sort honestly the
performative masculinity bit of of it
came later through reflection I didn't
realize that I was trying to be the most
outdoorsy the most man-like I know that
I can't throw a football or throw any
ball and I know that there are certain
like dude things that I just cannot
abide but I was like I don't know a
single dude who's ridden 14,000 miles on
a bicycle so at least I'll have that
uh-huh like metal on my jacket but that
was not so much conscious until later I
knew that it would be a rite of passage
I intended that and and like that
especially maybe 10 years ago 15 years
ago there was a big move
like reclaiming masculinity in the
Christian world there was like a whole
wild at heart all these things and I
that impacted me where and one of the
things they talk about is like our
culture does not have a rite of passage
and especially for men like to go from a
boy to a man and a lot of traditional
cultures have had that for 50 thousand
years and I love that idea that that
sense of liturgy that sense of putting
your body and a thing that goes before I
was this and now I am this and I was
like well this is a very sign of the
times that I'm going through my rite of
passage not at 13 but 30 but with any
developed Society childhood is extended
so I extended it very far yeah and I
knew it was a rite of passage for me
intentional I didn't know what was on
the other side I didn't think it would
be so much about figuring out my faith I
didn't think it would be so much about
figuring out my relationship with my
family sexuality
god I really thought it would be going
from an amateur writer to embarking on a
project to become a real writer that was
what I was conscious of while it was
happening and it wasn't until the
reflection of actually writing the damn
thing that I realized what was really
happening
or what really had happened right you
had this I've read an interview with you
where you you quoted something your
friend John Shue said which is if you
want to be good at something you have to
do it first Yeah right he's he's an
amazing director he just directed crazy
radiations what an insane success story
oh my god I mean and I went to college
with him and he was a star in college
he's just an amazing so usually like
this guy was gonna yeah big movies but
he you know and he's like made a lot of
great movies but he this is his moment
to like become like to have the runway
to do whatever he wants yes I'm so proud
of him he's just the best person in the
world and he got asked quite often
because he's you know a darling of USC
so he'd go back and speak to the film
students and they dad
like what do you suggest like how do we
make it and he's like if you want to be
good you have to do it first if he's
like you have an iPhone or a samsung
something and that thing films really
well and if you're not making things all
the time then I don't believe you like
that just means you want to be famous
yeah you like the idea of being that
person but you're not actually in love
if you yea actual craft of what it is to
do it if you want to be a writer and you
don't write then you don't want to be a
writer you want to be known as a writer
mm-hmm if you want to be an actor and
you're not doing local theater you don't
wanna be an actor you want to be famous
it's like that's if you really want to
do something you'll do it wherever you
are and especially in this day and age I
mean some of my favorite music I find
out that the girl in London made it in
her bedroom on her laptop and put it on
soundcloud and now it's like my favorite
song in Los Angeles I think that's how
Lords first album was made yeah and you
know in some Canyon and New Zealand and
now she's a household name so if it is
if it doesn't bellow out of you out of
out of necessity then you're doing it
for the wrong reason and you cut your
teeth you literally cut your teeth as a
writer on Instagram well so I didn't
know I was a writer until I was told I
was so this happened in Invisible
Children I started you as I started as
their lawyer and then we would be in
meetings and trying to our figure out
how to articulate the campaign for high
schools how to like synthesize this
information and then they would ask me
what I thought and I would say what I
thought and they would be like write
that down that's exactly it
and that then that led to okay Jed will
you just write this out for us and then
we're gonna use that and then that led
to okay we don't want you to be our
lawyer anymore hire someone else and do
this full-time and then all of a sudden
they're telling me you're really gifted
at articulating synthesizing ideas in a
way that is approachable in a way that a
high school kid can understand this
complex issue and it just kept being
affirmed in me just something I was
doing naturally and it was right around
then that Malcolm Gladwell's book
outliers came
in that concept of 10,000 hours was
being talked about everywhere and I was
just sitting with some friends I don't
know we were doing drinking coffee and
we were like what would you would be
willing you know in our 20s we're trying
to figure out what is our 10,000 I was
like what would you be willing to even
do for 10,000 hours and for me it was I
donned on me in that moment well I
actually really enjoy writing and my
favorite thing in the world is
underlining sentences and books uh-huh
that's my favorite feeling when I when I
read something and somebody says it and
I didn't even know I didn't even know
you could articulate something so
perfectly that was just a great cloud in
my head I didn't even know I thought
until I read it I it would be my dream
to create sentences like that and I'll
be willing to spend 10,000 hours doing
it and so that gave me the confidence
when I started my bike trip well it gave
me the confidence to then commit to I
want to be a writer I'm gonna do this
trip I'm gonna write about it and also
I'm gonna write about it online and just
yeah see if I'm any good and that and I
was just really willing to to risk it
and maybe be bad yeah I don't know but
that declarative act of like saying out
loud I think is so important well the
same way that that's how your bike trip
actually came to be right you had to
like announce it 100 I mean I am a
coward I love to cancel plans I love to
think I'm gonna do something and then
not and so I knew I needed social
pressure and I needed to announce I'm
gonna do this thing everyone's got to
know three years out so that I can't I
mean it's not like road tripping to
Yosemite it was a year and a half on a
bicycle in countries where my mom told
me I would be beheaded so that's like a
big deal I know they're really psyched
myself and in this three-year period of
preparing to do this ride actually there
wasn't that much preparation right there
was there was yeah you're acclimating to
the idea but during this phase it didn't
dawn on you that you were in certain
respects walking in the footsteps of
your parents who were made
famous by their amazing trek across
America which we talked about last night
right but it's like how is that possible
that it didn't occur to you that you
were doing something that was so so much
so similar in so many ways to that
defining you know act that they are most
well-known for you know really looking
back on it I think a lot of that has to
do with this theme of
compartmentalization that we've been
talking about I in order to not ruffle
the feathers of my family I really built
my own life I went to high school alone
my sister and brother went to different
high schools I just really felt
autonomous and so that's what's funny is
like I didn't acknowledge that I was the
result of an amazing family of an
amazing upbringing of an incredible
faith tradition of a sense of safety of
creative parents who encourage
creativity and fearlessness and do what
you love I was just I thought I was this
the likes unique flower that grew in a
desert and you know that is just a real
awakening when all the sudden you're
literally imitating your parents almost
exactly and and their and their vocation
like travel writing memoir I invented
that right category yeah it's it's
incredible how willfully it will for it
willfully ignorant I can be I want to
explore the the faith aspect of this a
little bit more deeply like in the in
the process of this adventure that you
go on how hat you know and in the wake
of that and now writing about it like
where where are you today in your
relationship to Christianity your faith
the Evangelical Church I've really been
influenced by a teacher named father
Richard Rohr
he's a Franciscan friar I believe and
he's written a lot about non-dualism and
similar to his amazing writers like
Thomas Merton and he's kind of expanded
outside of
is just this or that you believe Jesus
is the Son of God or you don't you
believe he literally rose from the dead
on the third day or you don't you're a
Christian or you're not and there's such
a Simplot that's such a simplistic view
of the world and what father Richard
says is the path to enlightenment is to
transcend and include and so when you
move when you feel like you've moved
through something and it's no longer for
you understand that it was for you
because it brought you here mmm
and and it's not saying that like I'm
wiser than evangelical Christianity or
something I'm just saying that I tried
it I tried it my damndest I went full
bore and had my first kiss at 28 first
time I had sex was 30 and that's because
I tried it real hard I went I led Bible
studies I would like leave law school
every Tuesday every Friday and lead
these high school Bible studies because
I'm gonna be the best I'm gonna like
fail my classes I almost failed a
semester of law school because a friend
of mine went into a coma and we did
intercessory prayer every night I didn't
sleep I didn't even go to classes trying
to save him which didn't work and I mean
I did a full-bore that and it did that
just that worldview did not serve me to
speak very pragmatically and yeah it
certainly did serve me it like gave me a
lot of the infrastructure of my mind
which I now hold very dear and so but to
transcend and include is to thank it for
what it is but and and understand that
it's incredibly integral into the fabric
of reality but also there's more and so
I would say I still not call myself a
Christian I would call myself a mystic
Christian in the sense where I reject I
reject as a strong word I do not feel
drawn to evangelical Christianity's
obsession with certainty either you
believe the Bible like us or you're
deceived you know like this is exactly
how old the earth is this is exact
what God meant there's just a lot of
obsession with certainty because when
the world is chaotic it's actually nice
to know some some things for certain and
to have somebody stand onstage and tell
you life is exactly like this and if you
do a B and C you're gonna live for
eternity and paradise if you if your
world is falling apart that is very
comforting yeah it's an antidote to fear
it allows you to sleep well at night and
and so I really respect and love that
and I love Jesus and I I believe a lot
of things about Jesus but I just don't
believe in the certainty and the
exclusion and the the tightness of that
narrative anymore it sounds not
dissimilar from the kind of things that
rob belt talks about well that's I mean
the the ever-widening circle if you go
on this journey and you have the
disposition to be curious about other
ways of thinking and you don't lock in I
mean that was the thing where like there
was a evangelicalism never stood a
chance with me because I'm too curious
and I and I too deeply like hold things
with an open hand I don't love to me
locking in like this must be how life is
only this and then I see it bang up
against reality over and over and over
and over again and then all of a sudden
your brain has to be a lawyer to like
convince you that your old worldview
still fits in with reality and you're
constantly in this like legal battle
with the worldview you accepted as truth
and new evidence I mean that's the
history of the Christian Church is them
like scrambling to and I was like that
just is not I I don't want to constantly
scramble I just want to hold it with an
open hand
and see what comes but also understand
that I come from a tradition I come from
a sincere relationship with God that I
still have and while my language may
have expanded my understanding my
understanding of the universe may have
changed expanded
I don't reject it I don't believe it I
don't want to even say it hurt me it
taught me I was at a conference this
past weekend on the East Coast and one
of the speaker's was so amazing this
woman
Nadia Bowles Webber have you ever heard
of her mm-hmm
she's a Lutheran pastor but if you saw
her you would think that she plays bass
in a punk rock band in the East Village
cool she's got sleeve tattoos down both
arms like this while gray hairs about my
age and just like fire in her eyes and
like this spirit and she walks like the
the caller but she cuts the sleeves off
the shirt she's just like I'm like I
love it
yeah like wow she was really really
powerful I'm gonna try to get her on the
podcast but you know pastor lutheran
pastor in Denver I mean it's a really
special thing there's I mean I don't
remember the exact statistic but it's
something like 85 million Americans
consider themselves born-again
Christians which is a lot it's almost a
third and that and then if you include
Catholics and all these other things
it's like most of America and so if you
cannot speak that language and you
cannot see the world that way then
you're then you're gonna lose a lot of
communication and connection with human
beings all around you it's such an
important point I mean is somebody who
who grew up in Tennessee
born of the evangelical tradition this
this mystics stuck in a millennial body
as in Tom Shadyac this referred to you
as and as somebody who you know grew up
in it and and what sounds like a
relatively conservative community but
you being this progressive how do you
you know what's your perspective when
you look at the dialogue that we're
having right now about culture about
politics
about social mores it's a very toxic
scenario that we find ourselves and and
I'm always thinking about ways to bridge
that divide you know we're so siloed of
course I mean it's a it's a trope at
this point but if we don't find ways to
exude compassion and ways of shelving
our judgement in the interest of trying
to bridge this divide so that we can be
the United the United States of America
we're in big trouble
well Jonathan Hite talks a lot about
this in his book righteous mind which
was so influential am I thinking I
recommend everybody read it but in in
order to have unity of any kind of
nationalistic unity you need a common
enemy so the more divided a country gets
often it means the more the more we
bicker about smaller and smaller things
it's actually like a it signifies a
pretty healthy society where you're
freaking out over little nuance things
happening in government whereas like
when you have a common enemy like Pearl
Harbor or Hitler I mean that's why the
greatest the greatest generation rose
out of the world having a common enemy
the Axis powers and it's it created this
entire generation of Americans that felt
unified in we are America we stand for
virtue we stand for valor we stand for
democracy against tyrants and you still
see people using that language in a
generation like mine where war is so
bifurcated into things that don't feel
like war they feel like response to
terrorism they feel like so provincial
and strange and alien and and complex
and like why are we even fighting this
to where now you know a lot of people my
age see someone in uniform and they have
mixed emotions about it they're not like
wow what a hero they're like wow what
are you doing over there
you know and that really you know the
breakdown probably be
with Vietnam I wasn't alive but what I
perceive of history and so and we felt
it a little bit in my lifetime with 9/11
where America became America for like
six months or something and I remember
feeling that like I remember seeing an
American flag on like September 19th
2001 and thinking I love this country
and what we stand for and I want to kiss
everyone I see on the street because
there was this idea of having a common
enemy we're very complex apes who are a
tribe and our tribes have just continued
to expand so the more complex we get the
the more difficult it will be to have
unity as a globalized world as a nation
and so you've all her re as he said on
your show thinks climate change could do
that but as you said it's so ephemeral
it's really hard to like hate a
temperature degree difference yeah you
know like what does that even look like
in terms of the way in which we speak to
each other and the like complete falling
apart of civil discourse I think a lot
of it has to do with us reverting to
these natural instincts of creating
enemies out of those that disagree with
us you the moment you can like call a
group of people cockroaches you
dehumanize them and you know or
deplorable or whatever you want to say
and you you create a categorical
stereotype that is now able to be
crushed and I was listening to this
interview of Oprah by Van Jones the
other day and Van Jones asked her if you
had 10 minutes alone with Donald Trump
what would you say to him and I loved
her answer I'm still thinking about her
answer but she said I don't know I don't
really speak to people if I won't I
won't speak to someone if I know I won't
be heard mm-hmm
and so I'd probably be silent or she
said something like that and I really
thought about if you can't be heard and
this is what happens when a liberal and
a conservative are shouting at each
other yeah
listening no one's listening I mean and
that's actually brain chemistry when
you're in an argument the part of your
brain that learned some information
loses blood the part of your brain that
is the filing cabinets of your own
argument is raging with neuron like
firing and so you the part of you that
learns is turned off the part of you the
defense it's pre held positions is on
raging and so heated arguments that's
why that's why nothing good has ever
happened on Twitter except being
surprised by news is like no one in a
Twitter battle ever reaches a new idea
it's rare I'm sure it's happened but so
I think I think there's places certainly
important places for people to be angry
anger is an expression of pain is an
important expression of pain and it gets
attention and draws attention to a cause
and then I think there's important
places for people who fly 30,000 feet
above and say let's understand where
you're coming from let's understand
where you're coming from and let's let
let you both reach a place of relative
safety where you can hear each other and
so how do you do that in a one-on-one I
mean you live you live in Silver Lake
but you you go home like you're home all
the time right you're in Tennessee
you're you're you're you're part of that
community still back there
oh yeah so when you are engaging
somebody you know one-on-one or at a
dinner party or you're with your mom
what does that look like if you do not
have respect for the person you're
talking to and if you cannot entertain
the fact that you might be wrong you
cannot have civil discourse it's it
becomes charity at that point it becomes
patronizing it becomes propaganda
I don't know that everything I believe
is true I believe certain things have
significant evidence and other things do
not I've never seen a polar bear die
from global warming but I know a lot of
scientists agree that it's happening and
so I tend to trust experts I
and a progressive person I'm socially
progressive I've seen how progressive
policies have impacted my life as a gay
man and the life of my black friends the
life of my people who have people of
color in my life I've seen how
progressive policies have changed
history I've also seen how hyper
far-left policies have destroyed entire
nations and so fiscally conservative
people have a lot of good ideas I and I
for me you can have a good conversation
with anyone if you're curious about what
they think and why they think it and a
lot of times people have never asked
them and so I tend to remove myself I
feel like a very small ant on a very
large planet and so screaming at my
cousin for voting for Trump and
believing that climate change is not
real feels like it's gonna give me high
blood pressure and I don't know what's
gonna change mm-hmm whereas if I am
curious about why he thinks that way and
then I make him feel safe and respected
he may be curious about why I feel that
way and I mean and I've had conservative
friends tell me you're the only liberal
person I can talk to mm-hmm and they're
like why is everyone so angry and you
know and I like try to break it down and
I'm like because they're scared
yeah and that that's a two-way street
but I think if you approach those
conversations from a perspective of of
curiosity like you said you know or to
come from this place of that's
interesting tell me more about that you
know I want to understand and I feel
like that's the note I play and the
conversation that's my personality I
believe that the angry screaming
activist is also an instrument in the
orchestra
I believe it yeah although everybody has
their part to play those people are
important because they they they tow
that line or they show you where that
line is and they not they may not be
converting people to their perspective
but they're letting you know where the
where that line for them exists and I'll
speak from experience this hat
Furguson the Marches and Ferguson
happened in 2014 miles on my bike trip
and I thought I was this open-eyed
progressive Los Angeles person and I
remember they were marching through the
streets and I was like why are these
black people so angry like how did they
just mobilize after this one random
person was killed like I just was so
ignorant and that rage and mobilization
that I was like there must be some
current of truth and what's going on and
what they're saying are they these
people could not unify to make a
statement like this the streets are full
of weeping black people and that like
that expression of rage anger woke me up
2x start asking questions and say
clearly what I thought was a post-racial
America was wrong mm-hmm and that is
like obviously let our whole country
down this conversation and the tipping
point was anger very true you know very
true I've had my own journey with that
as well where you think oh you know I'm
a liberal I know what's going on and
then something gets thrown in your face
and you realize like I still have growth
yeah in this place but to be able to
hear that and not just react and be
defensive but to like take it in
pause meditate for ten minutes well and
it's and people who are defensive people
who are quick to anger that is always
rooted in fear and the fact that feel
that admit just might be true and fear
that that their safety is compromised
you know it and it's sincere and so you
learning like through other people of
course some people are hot Headz and
they're angry too often over small
things but often times especially when
there's an entire angry culture or
there's an entire movement then you need
to listen that there is truth there is
deep truth woven in there that is the
immune system of humanity flaring up
mm-hmm
speaking of truth truth is the
touchstone
in your writing it's all about personal
truth and trying to find a way to tap
into universal universal truth by by
expressing your personal truth and I
know firsthand how difficult that can be
when you're writing a book that people
are going to read and there's other
human beings involved that happen to be
real people in your life mmm so how do
you how did you you know tiptoe around
that yeah when you if you want to write
memoirs and you write about your real
life it's really hard because you don't
live probably you don't live alone on an
island you live around people that you
love who maybe there aren't maybe they
aren't even villains or evil maybe they
love you and through their love of you
they hurt you do you know I'm saying
like this is my relationship with my
family they all we love each other so
much and by very nature of doing your
best and the circumstance of my identity
and figuring it out there there was pain
mm-hmm and everyone is doing their best
and just outpouring love and there's
incredible pain and it wasn't
intentional the infliction of that pain
ever and none of them signed up to be
written about in a book exactly and so
one thing that was really influential
for me was I was I bought Jack Kerouac
book Big Sur I think it was this book
there's one of his books and III always
read the introduction because these like
literary professors write such great
like overviews of what's going on and
one of the things this intro said was
Jack Kerouac his books are full of
colorful inappropriate wild people and
you'll never hear him say a bad word
about any of them and what it is is he's
able to paint these people but you can
tell he likes them even though they're
doing the craziest and they're
being horrible to him or whatever he
likes them and you can read you can feel
that in the page and in on the page and
in the way he talks about them and I am
that way I don't have any enemies in
this world
I couldn't love my family more I I love
them the most I couldn't love my friend
Weston who went on the trip with me his
real name is Philip and he is the well
if you're gonna say it here why didn't
you just write Philip in the book well
no the thing is it's the same reason SIA
covers her face with a wig
you can google her face at any moment
uh-huh but it's just just one level it's
one one step removed just gives like I
don't know a little bit more privacy and
he is very wild in the book I mean
compared to me who's like recovering
goody two-shoes so I was just like I'm
gonna give you one step removed he
didn't want me to do that I just wanted
to uh-huh
and that's probably a little bit of
being triggered by kony2012 and you
never know when you put something out
into the world how people are gonna take
it and so I was like I'm just gonna give
you one one click but I wanted to write
honestly about people from the position
of I love you but what you do is
interesting and that kind of like
disconnection and disassociation I hope
is conveyed in the book did you have
that conversation with certain people
beforehand no I did it afterwards well
with Philip I did he said he gave me
permission to write whatever I wanted
with my parents I didn't I actually
thought I was extra loving and generous
and trying to write about them but also
truthfully and it was hard my mom read
the book and was really hurt by the way
I spoke about her and that's you know if
I'm just like rich you're like one of
the best guys were like best friends and
just like you know you're kind of like
he's kind of cheap but he's like the
best guy like all you'll hear is you
think I'm cheap you know you you your
brain the if someone speaks about you in
anything but a overflowing league
congratulatory or celebratory way that's
what you latch on to
especially when they have somewhat of a
it's gonna be in public and you don't
have a way to defend yourself or give
your own perspective I learned so much
about my mom
from her reaction to my book and my
misunderstanding of my own childhood I
now such as such as I thought she was
this like just Jesus loving I mean she
is person who forced us to go to church
all the time because we just had to love
Jesus little did I really comprehend how
hard it is to raise three kids alone and
when your dad is off somewhere writing
books and not in the picture enough and
it's on you and you have no money
the only real safe place to go in in
that time was for her to take us to all
these church events and take us on
retreats and make us go anything because
it's like I can't handle all these kids
at once I mean I have friends who are
married raising lunch kid right now and
they can hardly brush their teeth
so I'm like how on earth did my mother
do this I have no idea and so that's
something of course I never perceived
that my mom was a human until I was
about 22 I thought she was this like
force of nature as a lot of us do and
there are those moments that land on you
like bricks where you realize the your
your mom is a 16 year old girl who got
older you know your mom is you who got a
little older and that I mean that's just
things I can't see and when you look
back on your own childhood your truth is
is your truth so I don't I didn't change
it in the book of how I perceived it cuz
that is exactly how it is but she gave
me some perspectives of her experience
that I was like wow I and I included
some of that in there and is she okay
now she's nervous about the book coming
out listen she's a she is a wise woman
who's been through a lot and walked
across America and had a very public
brutal divorce with a famous author and
her
and she's lived and so she is not a
fragile woman and she's got got on her
side and yes she does yes she does so
I'm not worried about her I mean our
relationship is complicated you know and
it's I mean I'm in that flux as we
record this podcast I don't know when I
talk to her next what it'll be like you
know so but we we both even when we have
really intense email exchanges we're not
very confrontational in person but we
can get we're both writers so we get
real deep in the emails and there they
begin it's almost like we took conflict
resolution courses they beat off they
always begin and end with utter
adoration and love and I will never
leave you will never stop loving you and
then you say the really hard and
then you land it with I will never stop
loving you I will never leave you I will
be there and that like so it's safe it
just it allows you to like express this
thing and no you're not about to lose a
relationship there might be boundaries
there might be things we never see eye
to eye on but the relate that the
foundation of the relationship will
never leave right barb right yeah yeah
dream the best is what do you do these
Instagram stories and you're with barb
and she's getting loose with her friends
pay unbelievable no they're they're I
mean they're like this is the thing
she's very easy to love I mean she's the
most incredible woman my dad is an
amazing man my family is amazing but
that's that's the big complicated I mean
I guess what I'm not I'm not like the
first person to write about I'm not the
first gay boy to write about their
mother and a memoir do you know I'm
saying is is like Warren territory right
but it's not running with scissors no
it's different and that's like what's so
interesting is every time you hear
someone tell a true story no matter how
extreme it is you're able to transpose
that over your life and glean some truth
about
your own experience one of my one of my
best friends out here has raised this
beautiful woman she's raised Orthodox
Jewish and never met a Gentile until she
was 19 mm-hmm like then lived on like
Pico Robertson like right in the middle
of LA and incredibly Jewish family
incredible Jewish family and she is in
her 30s now and unmarried and that's
really hard for her family and she feels
like a failure and yet she she also is
like the dopest girl I've ever met and
the coolest and lives the most amazing
life and everyone loves her and is so
successful
and she has this so similar to me
experience of shame and the influence of
the culture and tradition in which she
was raised her love of God and wanted to
do right by God her love of family I
wanted to do right by family and so when
I was telling her about my book and and
how it breaks down she started like
crying and she was like that's my story
well I'm like no it's not I'm a gay
Christian boy and she's like no that is
my exact story and so it's just
interesting how that's that's because
it's the truth
supersedes all right and if you're
speaking from a place of truth you're
gonna you're gonna tap into some vein of
humanity that we all share and that's
what great writing is well and that's
where I remember reading I think it's
the Paris Review they do these amazing
collections of author interviews and one
of the guy the guy interviewed this
woman and said what when you're writing
this novel did you know what it would
mean did you did you like intentionally
put in your message in the story and
she's like I don't believe in doing that
she's like I just believe in telling
true stories because the truth is the
teacher not me and so if I just tell the
truth
then it'll have a message whatever
message is meant to be conveyed will
percolate out right and the moment you
try to be the teacher then you're
probably getting it a little wrong right
and so that's with this book I
they tried and you can tell I'm very
open about everything and I'm very much
so like that in the book because I'm
like it doesn't serve me to hold a
secret it's it's inside my core and like
burns and rots I might as well puke it
up in this book and then it's out there
and then I saw this with I've seen this
happen time and time again especially in
the Christian world hidden secrets that
destroy someone's reputation and
identity when they come out later
destroy and so I'm like well if I have
no secrets then guess what you can't
destroy my reputation because it you if
you know me you know I can get anything
on you yeah because you're out about it
but that doesn't mean that it isn't
difficult to be that vulnerable on the
page it takes a lot of courage you know
to to be like okay am I really gonna say
this about myself or this thing that I'm
not proud of or this this you know event
that occurred around which I still
Harbor some shame right it's it's
terrifying you know a lot of that terror
is mitigated when you have a really
tight-knit community of friends that you
respect and that respect you if you let
them read pages I let one I let my best
friend Lauren read it first but I didn't
let people read it as I was going
because I didn't want I didn't want like
the ship to keep turning over and over
again at night I wanted to like get it
all out and then figure out what it was
and so once it was all out and my
editors went at it because I also my
editors didn't know me and so I really
respected their notes because most
readers of a book don't know you
hopefully and so if they're like this
doesn't make sense their notes are
important and um so once they had gone
through and we done all those edits then
I gave it to my friends to read just
because they're my true my goal is
actually to make them like it mm-hmm
if they
respect my work then I'm done because I
respect them the most and so and what's
so special about it is that the ones
that have read it are really touched by
it and they're proud of me and they've
underlined things which is my dream and
so you've already won hasn't even come
out yet
I feel 100% I feel people ask me am i
nervous
no I the thing is like I've written a
thing that is now a tool that I hope it
gets in the hands of a lot of people
struggling with identity and I'm proud
of it
my friends are proud of me that's you
live in a blessed life I know and that's
a thing is if you can if you are lucky
enough to find a community of friends
that you respect that respect to you you
a lot of things that people call courage
just become natural like being open and
honest about your life I don't fear
abandonment at all because my this
community of friends that I have know
everything about me and already won't
leave me I was gonna say you're somebody
who's amazing with friends and then I
realize like well I haven't seen you in
three years and I'm basing that entirely
on on this this like projected
relationship that I have with you based
on me following your social media but
all in dish' is there that you surround
yourself with a lot of good people that
you trust and rely on and you're very
much a part of a community yeah and that
is I'm a hyper social person I'm a
double extrovert I get energy by being
around other people and I think by
speaking so if I'm alone I'm asleep and
or meditating now right yeah that's my
breathe so I just am very fortunate to
have tracked these people down and
forced them to be my friends against
their will and it's just I don't know I
really feel like when a human being is
in community they are most alive at
least for me
and then in the fullness of a purpose
and I didn't a lot of those things come
through when you feel part of and maybe
this is our evolved DNA to be in a tribe
and when the tribe is united and feeling
really close-knit you feel safe you feel
like you can take on any bad guys you
feel like you're gonna make it and with
that foundation of a sense of safety you
can start moving up Maslow's hierarchy
of needs you know you can start right
pursuing self-actualization you can
start cultivating respect and character
because the safety net is there yeah
that's a big for me that's the biggest
thing and I always when people are not
ready if you're 46 and if in the closet
if you don't feel safe I don't blame you
for staying in that closet if you're in
any kind of situation and you don't feel
safe that's courage when you step out
and you do not feel safe but something
and you demands that you take that step
I have rarely done that I mean I was
scared to do this bike trip for sure
that's like the most courageous thing
I've ever done but most of the things I
do are because I feel unconditional love
and therefore can really pursue the
truth of Who I am with gusto right
it's a powerful man it's really powerful
in the in the writing of this book the
original idea was that you were gonna do
this as a self-published thing right and
then a certain wise person talked to you
out of it
so I mean originally of course I wanted
to it to be published by a publisher but
I tried and no one was biting and my
item amazing this amazing agent and she
was like I'm sorry I've sent it to so
many people and they're just not biting
maybe we need to rework it I don't know
what was the feedback just this is a
travelogue the feedback was oh great
another gay guy like mad at his mom wow
you like are on a bicycle they're just
like and really it was really it was oh
you're like instant
I'm famous that's not legitimate
literature so no and and I was like well
you know and this Invisible Children
trained me to be like a raucous Punk so
I was like we're in a new time and
polishing is dying and I'm gonna self
publish and you're I'm gonna show you
and so I started and that is a way 100
percent it's a way and people have had a
huge success doing and it's an
incredible thing I do not mean to deny
that as I but one thing that I know that
I am is really scatterbrained and bad at
a lot of things that involve any level
of organization and so I was at a
conference up in Northern California
and Cheryl Strayed was there and I had
met her once before in telly right at a
film festival and so we kind of knew
each other hi hi hi you know and then I
had given a talk that morning so she had
heard me give my talk which like gives
you a little bit of legitimacy of like
they know a little bit about you he's
been vetted a little bit yeah so we're
we're sitting at lunch and she i
probably sat next to her just like he
this seat taken and sat there and she
goes tell me about this book you're
working on like what's it would tell me
about it and she's just like such a good
listener and there's she has this magic
Jinna say quoi that makes you just want
to tell her everything which is why
she's such a great advice columnist and
vise giver and I told her that I tried
to publish and know what he would buy it
and it's a new world and I'm just gonna
self publish and do it myself and she
said to me I mean I don't even know her
and she said to me okay do you want me
to encourage you or do you want my
advice
mmm which I loved I was like whoa badass
yes I want your advice I can take it and
she said if you're anything like me you
don't want to be a publicist a marketer
a copy editor and editor a shipping
company
and a graphic designer Agra fan develop
relationships with 6000 bookstores
across the u.s. if you're anything like
me you want to be a writer you want to
focus on writing and she was like you
can self publish if you want but all of
those other pieces are very important to
success and so what's great about
traditional publishing is that they are
professional they have hired actual
individuals who do all of those jobs
exceptionally well and so you get to
write and focus on writing and she was
like what I'm gonna tell you is that if
no one's biting I would say it's
probably not good enough yet you need to
keep working on it and that's a hard
pill to swallow but is the best advice
anyone ever gave me I said thank you I'm
gonna do that I'm gonna think about it
and then I'm gonna do that and right at
that moment I had this other agent reach
out to me and he said I can get your
book sold give me a chance and my other
my agent at the time who was a dream she
was like listen it's my job to get you a
book deal if I can do that for you go
for it like if someone thinks they can
like all I want is for you to get this
book done so she released me I went with
this new guy we reworked it retooled it
went out a couple months later and sold
it - did you go back to houses you had
already submitted - yes because that's
like that's not coming from zero that's
coming from behind yeah they already are
coming in saying didn't I say no to this
already yeah the thing is we went to
this new agent was older and had real
cred with certain imprints at these
agents or at these publishers and so he
was like we've reworked this I want you
to look at it again hmm
and they get so many submissions they
probably barely remembered what I had
submitted before and a few of them
really liked it and specifically penguin
Random House
his imprint convergent really liked it
and they courted me and I mean it was a
really special experience and a dream
come true and I think wow if Cheryl
Strayed hadn't hadn't spoken her truth
to me in a way that in which to bring it
back to what we were saying before I was
in a position to hear her mmm
I wasn't defense so it came your
millennial snowflake ISM yeah I hear let
the snowflake melt and just became water
and absorbed her and I heard her and it
changed my life and now I have this book
and she gave us this amazing blurb yeah
which we know oh my gosh she's so
special and such an incredible influence
on so many people's lives and as I step
into this world where I speak openly
about myself my problems my mistakes my
shames she has walked that road really
successfully if she's the
standard-bearer I mean for the three
people that are listening who don't know
who she is she wrote while this
incredible memoirs many beautiful ways
yeah yeah with her spoon she writes dear
sugars I guess it's also a podcast
amazing on she's an incredible human
being yeah so and for her to read the
book that was my biggest fear was for
her to be like oh proud of you you did
it you know like a very general look
what you did which is a code for I was
so bored and she really liked the book
and gave me this beautiful quote that
we're gonna print on the second pass and
just I mean that it's one thing to have
my best friends who know me to my core
get what I'm trying to say but to have
someone who like knows me tangentially
not really and really through a
professional context who is like the
peak of their career to look down at me
at the bottom of the mountain and say
you're doing a good job is really a
powerful thing to urge it's huge and
continuing in that vein of like mentors
and like for some reason you being this
magnet for hanging out with cool
people how did I know Tom Shadyac has
been like this mentor to you and has
I've just impact on you I mean how did
that come about and and you know what is
it that he injected into the jet
equation
he has injected more into the equation
than anyone in my life I would venture
to say in terms of giving me language to
restructure my entire thinking and
sometimes he did it in ways that I
wasn't able to hear like he told me
things that I didn't like that I liked
three years later and it's so funny they
like about storytelling or about about
my worldview I mean he he told me early
on when I was telling him that I don't
act on my sexuality because the Bible
says so he goes you got to let the Bible
go and I was not ready to hear that I
was like aha you're a heretic mm-hmm I
can't trust you anymore and and what he
meant by that is you can't worship the
Bible you need to worship God and
another thing he told me once when I'm
processing all this with him he's so
generous with his time to even talk to
me back then was you know I was talking
about dealing with sexuality and faith
and all these things and I was so deep
in it and he said Jed let me ask you a
question where does your allegiance lie
all right is your allegiance with your
tradition with is your allegiance with
Christianity or is your allegiance with
the truth and I was like well I think
that's a trick question because
Christianity is the truth but I would
say the truth and he goes okay that's
all I ask is that you keep it there and
that was like somebody with a hammer and
a nail and a marble statue ding ding
ding ding and making that one little
crack to break my whole worship of
certainty apart where if my allegiance
is with the truth then I do not fear new
evidence
from experience from the outside world
from my heart because the truth is the
truth is the truth it is unshakable so
God is not scared by someone challenging
him or her it the Bible is not scared
not the truth is not scared and yet
there was so much anxiety in defending
this tiny little bit of certain truth
that my worldview had and it was so
anxious of being perverted and changed
and somebody ruining it that when he
said that those words and when he said
it then it didn't land on me the way it
lands on me now he's just really good at
telling you things you're not ready to
hear and then you thank him years later
and so how does that manifest in your
life and in your awareness and in your
writing and how you carry yourself well
that I mean fully it manifests in I am
eternally teachable there is nothing
there is nothing that I believe that I
could not change my belief about because
I'm like I don't actually care what the
truth is I just believe that it exists
I have no allegiance to what I think it
is it could change mm-hmm and now of
course the more evidence really it's
like it's such a relief it is such a
relief I have nothing to defend and it
just the truth is God is so much bigger
that it doesn't need defense and and
that is such a exhale of life that I try
to embody every day so when you're
mining your psyche and your experience
to find that truth and make its way onto
the page what are the devices that you
use like what is the litmus test of
truth for you great question I think I
pursue truth not because it's important
but because it feels good it just when I
learn something new that feels true and
I recognize it as true it feels it is a
rush blaze of your feelings of course I
mean I don't actually
leave in anything but feelings I mean I
mean there's obviously math and physics
but humans are feelings and and our
limbic system is way older than the rest
of our frontal cortex so it's like
there's a lot of truth in there and when
I learn something new like my phone the
notes on section on my phone is full of
moments that where that electricity of
recognition shocked me and I'm like can
I write it down and then that often
become something I write about on
Instagram and I feel no compulsion to
write regularly
I feel no compulsion like oh I haven't
the moment I have an electric thought
I've write it down and then I process it
and then I put it out there and maybe
it's a dumb thought but it felt like
something true and I'm just gonna test
it and what's fun about put testing
those thoughts with the world is that if
you get pushback or someone says you're
thinking wrongly or that's not my
experience then I'm like ooh good point
you know like let's let's roll with this
and so yeah my litmus test is really as
I observe and absorb living as a human
being in my brain the pattern
recognition software in my brain
recognizes things work like this things
don't work like this so when some when I
see something new that lights up and
matches other patterns that interests me
yeah
and that is my second ding ding learnt
you've you've like conditioned yourself
to recognize it yeah you know it and and
then I try to find language for it and
oftentimes the language comes in just a
few words and then I'll unpack it which
is I mean is it's the best feeling it's
so it's my favorite thing when I read
these these posts on Instagram they're
so naturalistic but it feels like on
some level a stream of consciousness
mm-hmm but it's also so well crafted and
composed and I'm like god damn it it
looks like he wrote that in ten seconds
please tell me
took him like three hours to go
I mean sometimes usually it takes me
just I don't know 15 minutes there's not
huh where I like and I generally do it
where I type it out in the note section
so that I can like read it and reread it
yeah you don't just natively put it into
Instagram it depends on what it is I
used to do that a lot but then I would
Instagram would freeze or something and
I would lose it so a the composition
window is so narrow right and I need to
see it yeah so I do it in the notes
section and I'm normally like sitting on
my couch or at a coffee shop and it'll
just cut like I'll be reading a book or
doing some other work working on emails
and some electric thought will hit me
and I have to get it out or I can't work
and that's like we're posts come from
like they bother me
that's a lie so that's why you're a real
writer I have to yeah they I cannot
think about anything else until I figure
out how to word this and then once I've
like exhaled it then I can go about my
business mm-hmm so what is it that you
want people to take from this book hmm
my hope is and now that it's done I
hadn't actually read it until I recorded
the audiobook because in the past I had
read it over and over again during edits
and so I would keep catching things and
then like rewind rewrite it so it wasn't
this I'd never from below let me ask you
let me interrupt you to ask you one
question yeah did you have that
experience you were speaking about the
benefits of that Chelse trade was
telling you about like going with a
publisher and they handle all these
their expert and all these various
specialties with regard to publishing
did you have that experience where you
turned in the manuscript and you're like
this thing is tight like you're like
mm-hmm
every word is exactly the way that I
want it I've read it a million times the
punctuation is perfect and then they
have the copy editor go through it and
it comes back just you just keep there's
literally red marks on every row yeah
bloodbath it's like graphic write all
the amount of blood there's a censored
bar over it
I definitely had that except I turned it
in without having labored over every
word I am a external processor a lot of
my writing I never read again I just
this is first draft I wrote it now I
really hate you and then it's out and I
send it to them because I like wow I get
so caught up in thinking new thoughts
when I'm reading something that I'm like
I must have thought it best that time
because I'm just gonna go off on another
direction if I go back in there and it
and then once they in their clarity and
lucidity we're like this doesn't make
sense you jump from here to here I know
you want this to be an emotional moment
but you didn't set it up before to knock
it down so you got to set it up they
were really good at teaching me those
things and so there was many many
back-and-forth but I'm not I'm not
someone who Labor's over my words I just
I write like I speak I hope and it's
just like whatever I'm thinking yeah but
there is structure to it which is
interesting I mean when you tell the
truth like nature has structure so it
kind of comes out it's so interesting
the flow of the book and and how it's
said of him when I read it I was like
wow this really worked you know but I
credit my editors with that because I
don't know what I was doing yeah I think
you know what you're doing I mean some
simple guidelines of tell the truth try
to if you're gonna if something's gonna
happen you need to explain why it
matters
you know and set it up before like
little things like that I knew but
outside of that I've never done this
before
and so we're gonna work our way back to
that original question about what you
want people to take from the book but
but on this subject of you know going
through the book for the first time from
beginning to end when you do the
audiobook what is the you know what did
the book teach you like what I'm
interested in like your journey through
it from this place of what you thought
it would be when you began to what it is
now and and you know what that what that
process was like for you in terms of
you know a teachable moment for yourself
in the doing right that's Jon Chu yeah
as you did well it's funny because in in
the in like when scientists research
memory and stuff they when you tell a
memory the telling of it changes the
actual memory like the truest memory
you'll ever have is the one that you
tell for the first time is actually the
one you never tell you know it's like
the moment you speak it the neurons
rearrange and like there's stories from
my childhood that I've told so many
times I'm certain none of it's true any
right well you have that little profit
or a paragraph at the beginning of them
yeah yeah we just fine yeah
I say at the beginning of the book like
receive this book as you would a long
story told by a friend over dinner you
know and like if they're telling a long
story about their past you're not like
fact-checking them too hard even though
like in truth the book is very true but
there are things that I jumped over and
things I simplified because well you
have to do you have to define truth like
sometimes the truth of a story isn't in
the specific factual unfoldment about it
right totally
so what did it teach me well I would say
one thing is interesting is as you read
a book your brain constructs the
narrator and it can you can almost see
them you can feel them as a real person
and as you get to know them especially a
book written the first person which this
one is and what is interesting is that
narrator isn't exactly me which as I was
reading I was like whoa then there it's
like me
ish it's me with a little more
understanding than I had at the time
it's me a little bit clearer which is
like it's just an interesting thing to
like imagine myself as like a character
in a movie that looks like me with just
like the eyes are a little close
together and the beards a little huh but
something and and with a little bit
armed with a little bit more insight it
was a trip somewhere
bing-bang to like feel that and yeah I
don't know what else I learned I mean I
learned that it's really fun to read
your own book as I just had the best
time and it's fun to read it with a
director and an engineer through the
glass and they haven't read it and so
there or at least the engineer hasn't
read it and so they're experiencing like
sometimes I would see through the glass
he would be laughing or whatever and it
is just really cool to experience that
live exchange uh-huh
I don't know I don't know what I learned
well what do you want people to take
from it I would hope that people would
enjoy the book as an adventure story
because it is it really is I mean there
is so much magic in Latin America that
is put on display in this book and I was
so blessed by that entire part of the
world I mean oh my god
every country Mexico all of Central
America I mean Colombia Ecuador Peru
Bolivia Argentina Chile like each place
is so different and so special and so
that alone is like just young but then
the journey into the interior of who you
are what you believe and why if people
aren't taking that journey in their life
they're missing a huge part of what it
means to be human and as the title
suggests I hope that people are willing
to watch me do that in a beautiful
location in their imagination and it
gives them maybe some tools maybe some
do's and don'ts of taking that journey
themselves do you think that you would
have been able to take that journey
without going on this bike ride
yes I think a lot of people and I know
people in my own life who are on that
journey now well they have a
nine-to-five job not in LA but in other
cities no one works not enough you know
and but but I do believe that it helps
to take yourself out of the of the
structure that your life is built on
because it does shake you awake it does
expose patterns of thinking and other
ways of thinking and being when you go
and remove yourself from your comfort
zone that begin this process for you
there's a line in wilde I believe it is
where Cheryl straights mother told her
to put herself in the way of beauty and
I just think about that all the time
it's like you need to put yourself in
the way because it's not necessarily
gonna come through your front door
mm-hmm and yeah you have this beautiful
passage in the introduction where you
talk about how when we're young and
everything's new and everything's an
adventure and we have no preconceived
ideas about what to expect about what
you know is gonna happen when we walk
through the next door because everything
is shiny and different yeah and then we
we get you know inured to our to our
lives and even if we live interesting
happy dynamic lives we're still habits
of creature and there is a dimming
switch that occurs with that but when
you travel to new places suddenly you're
able to connect with that childlike
nature because everything is indeed new
again right well and of course we're
that way if we were shocked by
everything that happened every day we
would get nothing done you know like of
course we get used to things we're like
elf yeah everything exactly I mean we
don't want that but I will say there
cultivating childlike wonder once in a
while at different phases and
transitions in life is important and
does re sensitize you to the beauty of
life and also the willful choosing of
your own journey
and path you know accept and flow down
the river but also feel like you chose
it that's the beautiful sweet spot and
we have lost touch with these rites of
passage and these rituals that were part
and parcel of growing up in a bygone era
and there's something you know there's
something sad about that I mean there's
just a lot of things I I never grew up
in a real liturgical church where you
just like go through all these motions
and you have these readings and you go
to the front and you get the communion
but there is some I mean there's a
reason why those things have lasted
thousands of years there's there is
something about when the human when a
human performs something ceremony
ceremonious ceremony or ammonia yes my
words when a human performs something
ceremonial it's almost like language it
gives them a metaphor a frame around
this much bigger thing like a marriage
ceremony gives you a before and after a
whatever it is you know when someone
dies and you take their ashes out on a
surfboard and everyone circles around
and like that ceremony and reverence
gives that feeling that heaviness that
weight of before and after and that is
helpful in the human brain that likes
chapters I think ritual is important
even if these ceremonies are as simple
as you know the way you prepare tea oh
yeah or you know the 10 minutes of
meditation I think the more that we can
kind of connect with whatever is
primordial about that mmm
it grows our lives with with with a
level of meaning and depth that that we
know is true even if it doesn't seem to
make logical sense I hope to have kids
someday we'll see but if and when I do I
will I will like institutionalize a gap
year a gap to year a situation where
it's like you go from high school to
college and you were
and it's not going to be in this country
and you have to and it is like an every
kid knows that the younger ones like oh
god that's coming up and the other ones
like oh wow I mean something like that I
just feel is really powerful and you do
feel like removed from the conveyor belt
of Education and all of a sudden you
feel whoa I have to make my own money
whoa life is actually not that easy you
have to work hard I don't know so I'm
just like thinking like something like
that they're like my dad did this thing
with us which was really special which
is after we graduated college he took us
on solo adventures so when I graduated
college I went on a seven-week
motorcycle trip with my dad across the
US and we was all back roads no freeways
allowed and it was so special and I felt
so seen and loved by him and he had done
it with my sister and he did it with my
brother and whatever so and that felt
like I don't know if it was a rite of
passage but it definitely felt like a
tradition that I was a part of mm-hmm
and that I had earned finally my turn
which is a feeling people want to feel
yeah but adventure was sort of woven
into your your growing up experience you
guys want to present camping trips and
all kinds of stuff yeah well I mean and
both my parents were writers so if you
live in that world it's feast or famine
or famine and famine you know it's it's
rarely you make a lot of money so they
were big shots in the early 80s and made
some good money and then the coffers
dried up and so my childhood is like we
don't fly on planes
we don't go to fancy things so we go
camping because you can drive there and
it's cheap and so it's interesting my
love of camping and nature was also like
a bit of necessity for this is what we
can afford to do and still do things as
a family and see the world that we love
mm-hmm
yeah all right we got to wind this down
yeah I gotta pick up my daughters so
leave us with some parting thoughts
about the book about this journey that
you're about to embark on a new
adventure a new journey of
of going out and sharing about the book
I already asked you you know what you
want people to take away from the book
but you know I want to hear like if
there's one kind of core message that
you want to leave people with about your
writing about your life about this book
what would that be hmm I would say I
would say there's a lot of anxiety
stress sadness loneliness in the world
and if that is true one would hope that
the opposite is also true
and listen I don't know how it happened
I don't know who I am
I've had a lot of struggles in my life
but I am living my dream I am writing
every day to people who will actually
read it and seem to like it
I am surrounded by a community of
friends that I respect and respect me I
love my family it's complicated
we get in it but we love each other and
life is good and so I'm telling you that
when something is true the opposite is
also true and like a lot of times like
well am I just always going to hate my
job am I just always going to hate the
circumstance am I always going to have
not necessarily it can be really good
and I am so so grateful and to the
circumstances of my life and I don't
know how it happened by the way I do not
know do you live an amazing life I think
it's definitely true you cannot judge
your future based on your current
circumstances I think that universe
rewards those who strive and it is an
amazing arc to see you know this person
whose experience could have gone
sideways you know a gay kid feeling very
isolated and a shame
in an evangelical home I mean that's a
recipe for a lot of things but not
necessarily somebody who's literally
their best most authentic life
surrounded by people that love them and
in the fullest expression of your
creative voice so that is something to
be celebrated and it's icing on the cake
that that you are so gifted at writing
and so not just eloquent in your prose
but in your commitment to the truth and
there is true beauty in what you express
like I am so touched every time I get to
read one of your Instagram posts I'm
just I'm delighted by you in every
regard I think I think you really do
have a gift and this was awkward for me
because I didn't I was only able to read
the first 10 pages of this book and I
wish that I had read the whole thing but
I have no doubt that my praise would
only be more effusive and I wish you
only the best and I'm so excited for
this next chapter where you get to share
what I already know
with meme all over the country who are
going to now enjoy your words for the
very first time well it's a true true
privilege to talk to somebody as
thoughtful and big-hearted as you
because epiphanies just pour out my
brain because I'm just amazed the way
that you open someone up is truly unique
and why this podcast is so special why
you are so special I appreciate that man
so you're going out on the road if
people want to come and give you a hug
and and get a book signed by you how can
they learn more about where you're gonna
be and how to make that happen
yeah so October third I'll be at
Parnassus books in Nashville at 6:30
p.m. October 8th I'll be at Barnes &
Noble at the Grove in Los Angeles at
7:30 and then the there may be other
dates added on I don't have any yet
because I'm just kind of like I did a
tour this summer that I ended up in the
ER from stress because I had stress
caused gastritis from overexerting
myself loving on people I just like want
to hug everybody and talk until midnight
and my body was like just talking I do
that every day not all mother hugging
saying no I am indeed not and so I'm
just kind of taking care of myself a
little bit mmm and seeing what what
comes but yeah I mean if people want to
come hang I'll be those two places and
more more to come for sure cool and I
forgot to ask you about this this thing
that you're involved in oh yeah you
don't I beat a cop it's betta I was like
is it bite as there is no real way it's
a Swedish word and they pronounce it
like butta which we don't I don't know
but it's this travel mug company that I
designed and started with my friend just
because I was so tired of throwing away
so many cups and red cups at parties
paper cups of coffee shops I was like I
just want to carry one that is pretty
that is like me everywhere and then I
who knows I'll save a thousand cups a
year that's kind of cool and so that's
what I did and and so you designed that
yeah that's cool because I see these
things all over the place and all kinds
of people on social media are using them
and talking about them and yeah they're
cool it's very fun to make stuff I mean
that's like another podcast but it's
really fun
all right so people should buy this
thing where do you get that my beta B YT
a.com uh-huh and did you bring me a copy
of the freaking book I have one in my
car but there's one in the mail on its
way to you I mean if you just want to be
under water with books you're supposed
to get in like two days
I want your I need your book you mailed
it to me that's good enough yeah it's on
it it's like in this guy alright cool
I release you to your life if you want
to connect with Jed probably the best
way to do that is Instagram Joe Jenkins
where you can read his musings you have
a website but that's not really the gig
right I mean yeah there's like links of
like stuff the rod casts and interviews
I've done but right but the most
important thing is to pick up the book
to shake the sleeping self yeah this is
this podcast is going up soon its
September I mean by the time this is
going up but it's right when the book is
coming out I think so
pre-order it or just buy it and read the
audio it's time to go real
bookstore and just pick it up and get
the heart cover right yeah awesome thank
you my friend thank you much love much
much success with this book launch and
come back and talk to me again
you know I will and and and can we hang
out at least once
yeah yours piece
[Music]
you